frankly the best career advice I've ever
gotten was probably a go for God's sake
don't try to be a professional writer
you'll starve to death uh I I couldn't
follow that advice because I so badly
wanted to be a professional writer but
uh it was practice that writing is like
playing the violin it takes practice you
get better as you get older uh and uh
you just don't get beaten down by
rejection you don't think I deserve your
attention I think if your clients want
to sit on my shoulders and call
themselves tall they have a right to
give it a try but there's no requirement
that I enjoy sitting here listening to
people live you have part of my
attention you have the minimum amount
the rest of my attention is back at the
offices of Facebook where my colleagues
and I are doing things that no one in
this room including and especially your
clients are intellectually or creatively
capable of doing that I adequately
answer your condescending question